on this episode we bring fiber to the
house dariya be hey everybody this is
gary vay-ner-chuk and a sense of two or
four of the askgaryvee show
actually you know what switched because
I'm gonna use it as my India I'm pretty
excited about this show you know this is
a site this is really fun we I'm gonna
let this wonderful job and tell you who
he is and what we're doing here on this
episode but um you know much like
musically even snapchat before recently
that I finally did invest there certain
companies that I watch that I'm not
involved with I didn't make an angel
investment but I watch and they deliver
on a thesis that I believe in and the
company that I've teamed up with for
this campaign and then subsequently this
episode and I assume I don't know what
the questions give you so the themes of
the questions are delivering on a very
important thesis and so I don't know you
know I'm not in the left mind on
commercial like like you know I'm in the
you know content is you need to go down
the rabbit hole but these guys do for a
living because I know my audience and
for 80% of you there's something
meaningful that this platform can do for
you that will be good for your business
I think now that we have the search
engine will be able pill enough I think
I've brought it up maybe like 120
episodes ago but I believe that most
things are overpriced because of
inefficiency
I believe these guys have solved it to
some degree um and I'm just soup I'm
personally excited to be doing this with
you you know I don't team up for
contests or be the face of things ever
and I did it in two seconds because I am
I believe in the thesis so with that
unbelievable anointment that I'm sure
you'll chop up and used for other
behaviors why don't you tell the Vayner
nation of who you are and from what
company and then let's get into the show
sure guys thank you and thanks for your
trust and slugging us I think you you
nailed it you know you know 500 that
often happens by the way yeah attendee I
gotta listen fiber world largest
marketplace of services fiber was built
in order to provide the largest
catalogue of services for digital
needs of primary customers small
businesses entrepreneurs so upon a macro
preneur mom Prada any Prada you want
should go on fiber and financial
services amount you are going to five
million of services hundreds of thousand
of sellers are providing you their
talents and their skills or on graphic
design music energy of online marketing
programming and Dec each of them are
going to provide you with services that
will allow you to go faster and often
the entry price on fiber is going to be
ten times lower that you will find on
the back supply and demand supply and
demand they've built what to talk about
marketplaces you need both sides of the
final and that's why so many people fail
they pulled it off period and the story
helped me with this because sometimes I
don't stay up to date for everything I
headline read the things that I don't
dig deep into originally all the
services were five bucks that's correct
I think now that that is not the way it
is anymore right that's correct it what
how did you obviously you opened it up
and I obviously somebody who thinks to
the thing that they're willing to do a
logo or things of that if they want 30
bucks you had to open up that
marketplace that makes sense even when
you guys launched five six seven eight
years ago six years right I looked five
to my favorite number by the way so that
was originally caught my attention and
second I just believe in this it's
really no different than vaynermedia we
do everything that the biggest agencies
in the world do a lot cheaper because we
created a process now you did it better
because it's software and it's
marketplace I'm doing it a little bit
different cuz I'm building it for myself
different sort of different day but
what's going on now is how did you
figure out the creative way to make five
or name still stick or you just didn't
give a crap or is like five now the
bottom or like what do you what do you
guys do it's a good question
five-o is a brand Fargo is a community
and fiber is our name well put that
aside for once ago
how is we sort about to open what are
you doing when did you move from
everything is five bucks when did that
happen
it does happen gradually about the last
couple of years yes it's now this trend
is accelerating
what we're doing we we leave
we let up setup up complete pricing
freedom now sir one condition condition
what which is being able to scope well
the service so the price can be
understood what's the difference between
the logo at five dollars and the logo at
$50 and the logo of two hundred and
fifty dollars analog of five thousand
dollars we are helping and well
productizing that process for for each
of the category 103 cell degrees through
but I am understand how important I'm
sure you also agree and I'm sure you're
doing this because I just watched from
afar and I think you guys know so many
things right but I assume but maybe not
one of the differences between a logo
for fifty dollars and five thousand
dollars is ours that is that you can
scope yes
talent is not something you can scope
yeah so you have to leave room for the
gray exactly why is my keynote speech
six figures and somebody else's is ten
thousand dollars and we both talked
about social media cuz I'm [ __ ] better
so and this is where you wanna thank you
so you're right and I think and I again
you're right and I think what you have
to to think about Fiverr we focus on
that market where we are not going for
the three thousand logo either thousand
dollars logo what you're going to find
on Fiverr is you are going to have a
variety of option between zero and one
of the dollars I mean we gotta get into
shoka's have to be analyzed SS 0 I mean
no no I know you mean 5 let me just say
this and you guys know me we're now 300
deep in stress 250 I've been around for
10 years I don't do things with anything
because I just don't believe in most
things the reason I talk about Facebook
and snapchat 24/7 is because I believe
in them I am very aware of the community
that watches the show I am secretly this
is selfish I'm secretly pumped that a
lot of you don't know about this and
that literally it's going to be the
thing that helps your small thing over
the next year because you know have a
lot of money and you don't have
unlimited time and I think there's a ton
of services on this platform that are
grossly underpriced
the end so let's give questions let's do
it India who are you today my name is
Adam what do you do I do a lot of things
substitute asking questions or for shows
but I do marketing in fiber as well on
the side very concise and you know we
didn't actually you didn't actually say
you didn't saying we we were right we
weren't right into it why'd you tell the
vaynernation for five seconds who you
are I'm sure they're making assumptions
below your name yeah David Manila from
your physio at five bound 41 years ago
not so France first my parents first
generation in France very nice chat
would decided to move to New York at 22
years old for three months and I'm still
here and during the last 19 years the
last 19 years have been working with a
variety of startup and high-growth
company and I've developed that
expertise to scale business again let's
get into it
San Barry on Weibo asks how can I charge
more than other sellers in my market
without losing revenue nice nice
question I'm glad it's about to why when
you think about pricing it's about the Y
and the Y is often about quality and
what you just talked about you nailed it
on how to or can I justify your higher
price maybe we just released a new new
product on fibre for most of our sellers
and most of our categories now called
packages and what happens is that it
allows you to use a well-known marketing
techniques which is good better best
pricing that's right
[ __ ] you can start at 5 you can have a
package at 15 you can have a package at
30 so what you do is that it allows you
to own that entry price points that
allows you to build credibility to get
volume and to get customers that could
not afford to $50 but maybe at $50
what's going to happen is that you're
going to provide more time faster
delivery better better techniques and
more optional runs the logo you are
providing and this is how you should
price it I'm gonna go yes and I'm gonna
go and you could always go back take
risk you can always go back like let the
market decide like if you're 400 bucks
to make a logo and then
I promise you whatever you got last time
ask for more than next time figure out
what your cash flow is they'll it
depends on how fancy you are you what
you want to watch them you want to spend
worse I'm working on fiber how fancy are
you right like like do you want a nice
watch well then you need more money to
buy that watch but if you're willing to
live in the basement you could always go
back like you could go you can get not
it depends on you know what how many
knows can you take I did it for 400 now
I want 600 you come in no you come in no
if you're fancy you're going to go back
to 400 because you need the four
hundreds if you're not fancy and you can
wait and be patient then all of a sudden
you can do a whole bunch of waiting ten
knows get your first six hundred you
established market another thing howdy
Rach got his gig the other thing you can
do is you can understand the difference
between something that you want to do
for six hundred bucks but then somebody
asks you to do a logo and you do it for
free because the exposure is going to
allow you to get all the $600 ones that
you want to move on letti cab asks I
have a really hard time letting go of my
job I don't like it but I've been there
for so long I have loans to kids to
support a deep fear of leaving the
security and I'm not sure what it takes
to make it as a solopreneur any tips on
how to release the fear and decide
whether to take the risk I've got it
I'll go first this time punt leisure
punt leisure you can work look if you
work if you if I'm gonna call I'm gonna
call you out if you really mean that you
can live on six hours sleep so you have
18 hours
you have 18 goddamn hours I want to know
what you're doing with your 18 hours
because you can work your 9:00 to 5:00
and that's nine and you can travel for
an hour here and there respect
nice little solid commute oh you want to
be a family man Mazel Tov you can spend
two hours with your kids what do you do
with those other five hours
you're watching house of [ __ ] cards
you're playing Madden you're relaxing
from the other intense 10 Gary I already
spent 11 hours well great then don't
complain or want more respect that by
getting rest and this and that
were giving up opportunity to go into a
newer you want the audacity to have a 1%
life let's let's call what it is you
want to live as well as the 1 to 2% in
the world it's not very complicated the
math is very wrong like you if you want
to have one of the best lifes in the
world which is you live on your terms
you have to pay your dues to get there
and you have to be lucky enough to
figure out that you had talent in the
thing that you actually want to do
because you can work 24 hours a day and
if you stink at golf or you're not a
good content producer or your logos look
like the [ __ ] I would make then you're
going to lose so that's what you got to
do and 500 was built for you
fibre was built for those talented
individuals while trying to find but
it's for everybody yes yes for talented
and skilled individuals that wants to
find financial and professional
independence so what you have on fabric
today yes you have
sellers making six-digit a year and
afters look like a project I know you
want to say but like we they're all
going here's the punchline
what's the mechanics are you guys taking
like 20 percentage rates is that the
number of yeah listen by the way the
reason I went there because look he'll
he's a chief revenue officer it's all
going to sound like me how do you cure
cancer at fiver
how do you let go to the movement 5 like
it's all like let me say was time here
here's why I'm curious at the scale that
you guys are now not five or six years
ago four years ago they're giving up 20%
for that attention no different than an
eBay or an Amazon I think it's very
minor for the exposure and I think
there's a fiber and things like fiber um
but you guys are at scale since while
you're sitting here and social media
combo that if you can make that one plus
one equal four or something very real
there so yeah let's go a merchant asks I
understand both are important but if I
only had to pick one should I focus on
content marketing or paid ads I've
learned paid ads provide more results
with less effort thoughts that's up just
stop just good okay
I have that put I'm advising a few
startups and that question comes often
and I think it's about again most of
this question is about the why what are
you trying so what is a why under what
what are you trying to achieve right now
I'll tell you something which is
thinking that you can build a business
based on paid art at one point it's
going to catch up with you always does
we tolerate this because the creative is
the very most success in creative
business like a your business it's like
the product like your service the
creative like people look like by the
way you can get in front of everybody
with your ad if that creative is bad you
won't convert so just because like by
the way Fiat and you're exactly right
the answer is yes if it makes you more
money up front and that lets first of
all the person's gonna win because they
understand there's two different things
he or she already knows who was it the
immersion emerging that was they've got
he or she already knows that there's a
big difference between sales and
marketing paid advertising a sales
branding marketing content that's that's
what that is good and so I don't buy
these because Nike [ __ ] cookie me and
chased me around the internet and I gave
up and I bought that I do it blindly cuz
it's Nike love it so you know so we're
gonna agree on that one and I don't keep
it done let's go next one is that that I
think we got Mike asks as a copywriter
slash fiction writer a lot of work goes
uncredited
or remains private to buyers what's the
best way for me to showcase my business
without practical examples of my work
this is I mean four five inches it's a
very fair question you know five oh when
you come as a buyer you buy you on
fibrotic you buy your book on the metal
so and Gary's book please ideally so you
buy what you see you know but by what
you don't see is a little bit more
difficult so how do you do that it's
about your seller profile
it's about your skills it's about the
emotion and your talents on how to
describe your gig
on Fiverr it's about to show your
personality it's about to put your face
as you as your profile picture and not
use a design you want to create trust
and confidence to do that that would be
my character I would say this look again
I mean I'm gonna pound this because it's
just true they wouldn't be here you know
that so this is a great tool at what it
does you don't need to make every tool
do everything for you if you want to get
your name out there as this great writer
there's something called medium medium
is amazing you can get completely
discovered all day long right for free
for it you want exposure it comes at a
cost
it's called not getting paid for it
listen I wish you got paid a hundred
thousand dollars to write an article for
the New York Times and get money and
exposure I wish I also wish that I was
six foot five and could throw a 100
miles an hour so it could be a baseball
player like like you know what I mean
like wishing doesn't mean anything
here's the practical answer used you
don't use a screwdriver to hit in a nail
you have a whole tool belt and so you
don't need to make five or do this and
you don't need snapchat everyone's like
oh snapchat how are you going to target
you don't you just realize that every 13
25 year-olds on it and it's awareness
like so what I would say is it you know
it's funny it eluded that to a recall
when I said I see this social media 5
like I guess what I see is if you I
think if your designer or songwriter
things that nature using the fiber URL
on your Instagram to drive people there
to create transactions around your free
creative and Instagram environment could
be quite interesting it's a very subtle
way to throw a right hook without it
doing especially because of the oomph
now there's a lot of fibers I'm sure
there's a lot of marketplaces out there
but this now has the oomph in the same
way that a Facebook or some that make
sure an amazon has there's a lot of
bookstores on the Internet
once something hits scale and it's the
brand you take advantage of that and so
I would say write great stories for free
on platforms where people can see it
here's a good one go and search every
fiction or nonfiction Facebook page it
has a lot of followers and ask them if
you can write an original story for them
to post in their community I'm sure
there's something called fantasy land
fantasy where you write a great little
fantasy article and
story is when what kind of bed you that
it's a Facebook page and there's so I
think I'm a big oh yeah but look I think
there's some sort of silly page that
probably has four million
fantasy readers that people love that
Harry Potter and stuff like that you
write a great story for it they post
because they said yes or maybe they'll
charge a pretty exposure I don't know
heck you may have to get charged to
build your brand things that nature
nonetheless it's about exposure and
you've got to find the avenues that have
it and not every tool has to do
everything for you great last question
yep Cinco in Cinco de Mayo wait for that
comes your moment that was it look in
the camera big thank you for thank you
so much for my moment
thank you for my yeah um it comes from
just me oh seven what would have been
your first gig if you were a seller on
Fiverr and why that's cool
I look to mine would definitely have
been probably especially when I saw it
for fire I would have probably done
little hype videos for product I would
be the infomercial guy right over the
infomercial I was like this is delicious
twos like so I think I would have got
video is my medium and so I would have
created original video you know
redirects will shake your head exactly
I'm gonna pay everybody got a fantasy
land fantasy all your fantasy mem to
prepare it matter to touches the dragons
you love fantasy land fantasy nice I
took for me some Mike you know I'm very
mostly with that which is all of those
geeks are my children I don't want
nothing about that
what would know that's that's a comment
what are we what do you do well like
what could you sell for ten bucks so
I'll go with I'll go with is your SEM
services o SEO services got it that's
great that's grounded in your craft I
would have hired you to voice-over old
Wine Library TV episodes with proper
French accent I do that do question of
the day you now get to attack this is an
important moment you know you guys are
building something special you wanted to
team up with me for this contest which
we have to link up that has some
restrictions right New York
that's what I thought so New York except
she got you damn gonna live there the
contest we're doing you need to be based
there they need to be made recipe needs
to be based there no worries so if your
small businesses we have there's a
landing page under the video so we're
gonna link that up in Facebook and
YouTube Stefan you sometimes get freaky
on me got a gambler alright um this is
where you pass the question day they'll
be hundreds of answers on YouTube and
Facebook which will give you great
feedback so you should think about it
carefully could be about anything but as
the CRO I think it should be pretty
vibrant out but anything you like ask
any question like what do you want to
know from a lot of entrepreneurs solo
entrepreneurs what do you really want to
know what is your number one thing as an
entrepreneur I'll talk to two audiences
first audience which is sort of you who
are not comfortable with the online set
up I've mostly offline businesses what
is your main pain as you go into the
online business what do you need how can
we help you what is your number one pain
so we can solve it because it's your
number one goal for those of you who are
online within the far majority which are
if you're watching a show you are in the
online ecosystem and you're suffocate
the people that are not and and infer
from you what can we provide same
question but as an online entrepreneur
what are the services that we need to
provide you because you contacts Isis
today and we will offline entrepreneurs
online entrepreneurs please onto the su
question you got visiting you did a
really good job man got great energy you
keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
you